はっはっはっます
今日スヴィアにへレッツら全員ゴミも使いで今日は初めて増でさっぴーはろうぃんと
いうことなんですけども僕は安定の
一日中家にいます
頭が動いものを見つけました多分めちゃくちゃすごいと思うんですよ開けてみようと
思います幻獣かわかんないけど雑に上め
指示が降っております
[音楽]
僕はこれを待っていはいもう年度猫言うべきじゃ
あっ動画をなぜここに書いてあるんですけども女が入ってもらってだこれこれで強い
わけじゃなくてちょっとすごいギミックが入ってるんですよ
もちろんこんなんだけ入ってるんだから棒も招待しないですからねこれだけが止まら
何かが入ってるわけですよ
[音楽]
思ってるで帰っ
うんどえむだめだ
これ細いってダメなんだよなで早速ボソン顔いきます
[音楽]
ヌー職はるぅぅぅぅぅぅすごいとけと呪われるからね
母 why まずなどようですよだというわけね
な理由今45ですってマスクね
貴重入って行けてご覧下さいいい顔してるでしょ
よく見ると中目にライトっぽいの追善でコメントは控えせたんですよね人でこれすごい
んですよ見ててくださいよ俺ギミックだってこれをとって
me
[音楽]
ムートンどうぞのぞと動きます
re
うざー
あ止まっちゃったを挽く遺産コア
位
してい
する返せよ
止まっちゃった僕
まあある
ワールド部分がちょっと気セットしてみます
[音楽]
me
止まるんですけどもう1回稽古の頭を触ると動き出します
[音楽]
海藤花で今ので分かりましたこれでも音が止まっている状態
こんな状態ですこの状態性もノートを建てるという
動くんで誰かが入ってきて置いておいてものを取れば部動くと思うんで
それで生み出せましょうねマジでで化したと蛍光前
これ怖くないですか要するにものてと杖動き出すんできた人た2大の強いものだと思う
んですけどそれ反応することによって多分めちゃくちゃ強いと思いますこれでは
さっそくハロウィンということで
を出してい
気持ちの良い尾根これ着税ちゃったさ純粋に言えない匂い解けたけど強いのではないの
か
もう雑に家の前に多いとかをそれが一番怖い気がしてきました
山 the god 3月かけてみましょうか
none
させてください
ヒューム
派というわけでこうきゃ抜群だったい今日早速いろんな人に仕掛けていきましょう
はっぴ省い
[音楽]
ええええええ
ん
うぉっ
ああああああ
pandan
[音楽]
me
re too
re の
ああああああ
[音楽]
持っていた
国華園まで公夫婦
んんんんん
無痛
コーナー
重要なリアクションだったかー
すごい質感のめっちゃ人間の真珠
[音楽]
言えばと思っ
ああああああ
カートセコイ
[音楽]
r 2
うわぁ
me
ni
[音楽]